also ich schlachte tragen die schweren
und gerne wieder aufwache also dass ich
wirklich unvorstellbare situation für
mich manchmal schuljahr am herzen liegen
wir jetzt immer schlimmer
kroner betrifft ist augen aber jetzt für
die jungen chance zwischen menschen mit
ausgang die kollegen weniger dating
schweden und reise eigentlich unmöglich
für mich persönlich das mega wichtig
soziale kontakte
das gestaltet den wirkungsort wie können
wir jetzt mit einem mühsamen zustand
umkommen in mexiko verschiebt für
zeitungen ist das dilemma zwischen
sozial standort und gleichzeitig
schränkte freie zu sehen wenn man machen
was man immer so gemacht hat und dann
plötzlich egal
[Musik]
als erste grippe-pandemie mut noch mit
der la coruna und melanie studieren muss
nicht nur sondern sich auch von zu und
setzte selbst am samstag aber casinos
gang sondern mit später auf nachtschicht
und westen jahren wobei die jungs cool
im ganztag auf ernannt bis jetzt können
wir mit recht gut aber wir möchten sich
sage ich ließ mir sagen dass man hat nun
studio tisch an ihn gerichtet sind mit
pool stuhl und ergonomischen dass ich
mich das problem mit den anderen
bis jetzt sehe ich weder co
also ich langsam auf rang acht schwierig
funde wie richard im umfeld also wir uns
drauf haben wir dann alle zu recht ist
sollte man sie zu umarmen
mir ist das mega wichtig durch den
kontakten wird also ein bisschen sozial
die masse in der regel ihrem sozialen
umfeld omega geschäft aber mir hat er
bereits spekuliert dass corinna die haie
und mein wenn ich drei manager die haie
werden dass das geld für mich auch
während dem lockt dann ja wirklich alles
karte meine sicher chance der wirtschaft
so wie sie jetzt im flachs sie haben
eine frage schaffen
ich will mich schon aber ich liebe
pflichten gegenüber aber gegenüber der
sich mit mega hub floss wie jetzt die
ganze zeit jedes wochen an irgendwas
gemacht haben mich mit 70 weitere
vorhaben dass ich sicher so sind wie wir
die sache womöglich im nachhinein
vielleicht dann okay ich jetzt
vielleicht ne zu machen wie zum beispiel
also mein ventil jungen singer
bestellstatus ebenfalls die erschließung
vielleicht mal und dann gehe ich mal
übertroffen
[Musik]
aber darüber leitet schon ganz anders
trifft man öfter oder zum beispiel mehr
direkt inhalte oder ich frage dann
ziemlich platt person rief erhalte
studiert und wenn es dann heißt jedes
wochenende mit anderen lied für mich der
fall klar und dann treffe ich die person
nicht was ich mich bereits auf und mache
ich halt den gar nicht mit der person
triffst spazieren und dann ist mal
wieder an der frischen luft man hat sich
lieb standen rät sich nicht direkt und
sexting ist mirko corona kommt
[Gelächter]
eigentlich klar okay mit mir und der
abstand halten
da ist jetzt mal keine und es ist nicht
so dass nur das ist laut nur das
körperliche und das finde ich persönlich
gar nicht so schlecht wurde
[Musik]
also ich bin mal weg kommen einmal in
gang komme aber halt auch in masse sowie
nichts für mich an keinen vertreter
fühle mich verpflichtet am zunächst wie
sie gegenüber spinne wahllos kopflos
jedes wochenende das ist ja nicht
einfach zu versuchen und 3 annika aus
sondern es geht darum dass man zusammen
ist es mit seiner kritik hatten das
haben mir braucht das nicht okay
verantworte mann der 80 geburtstag vor
jedem großpapa stadt ein wenig vor sich
allerdings kann also ich glaube
unabhängig vom alter ich möchte an
jemanden auch eine schule sie dass die
person wegen ihr dann die krankheit und
schlimmstenfalls stimmt und ich glaube
dass ich halte einfach dann vernunft
wurden
überlegt
[Musik]
und auch weniger ausgaben
diese geil zimmer mannschaft um die 20
von maxi zum nachtisch
ich muss geschaffen mit so
offensichtlich dass sie auf den 8
und denkt der wege mit kollege will die
schaffte alexander kron eine minute lang
übrigens corona corinna das beschäftigt
die 11
doch auch wenn ja wo
[Musik]
willkommen im bund aber im fall der ohne
dass in dieser nacht ist creepy vom hd
11 bis morgen am prinzip nie etwas
verschwitzt der pause herrscht pause
die letzten patienten abgeordnet will
mir sinus 2008 wir probieren einfach
ganz gut klappt das mit jedem die hand
aber jetzt haben wir ja bei mir egal ich
dass patienten mit moskauer duma
übrigens ist das mitte april an ist es
lief also die job ist schon strange noch
schlimmer wurde
flexibilität umrahmt eigentlich lag mit
denen sich ständig ändernde maßnahme
dass ich sicher viel stärker wurde habe
ich schaffe nicht mehr dick dann bin ich
ziemlich spieler wochen lang im spital
und es hat schon wieder ganz viel
neuanträge geht das ist mega bis
herausforderer taxi das team mega gut
mit landschaft ist eine entwicklung die
sich versteckt teambuilding
die situation also und situation am
boden bleiben sie also was mir sich
jetzt wehren der korona situation
blieben ich sind schon die suizid für
sie aufgrund folgerungen will wie sie
liebt können wirklich schlachter mit
isolation ungar wie andere die ditib
dass viel mehr gemerkt das lied als
existenz existenz von denen lüthis
betroffen von der pandemie macht das
angst
wir machen einfach an geschwindigkeit
weiß wie lange das noch so weiter geht
als das lautstarke geschenk das ist
ungewohnt für os mit windstärke 2 bis
ich die zweite wahl
wie kann er das ganz sicher aber ich
hätte jetzt kalusche rechts von ihm
dabei diese solartechnik und könnten
sich ahlen wichtig auffangen und sich
heraus wichtiges zeichen also
notwendigkeit 1000 mir jetzt wenige
fragen sich hin
das wird jetzt einfach man sieht dass
man das zeigt aber es klang wie ein
tropfen auf dem heißen stein sind
wirklich eindeutig mehr blüht wo nicht
nach der ausbildung plugin glied wo
bliebe die klage eines psychisch hat man
sie lange in der schlange geschafft
jetzt ist einfach gerade sehr bewusst
aber das gefühl wann etwas gemacht wird
ganz einfach wieder in vergessenheit
es ist zweitens die lizenz in der partie
den start
ich glaub mir leid danke für ein stück
land danken job
danke
männer mit auge ja irgendwie ist krank
macht und das ok das problem wirklich so
glücklich und das tut not reality check
und das vitalis of reality check
sessions geschlachtet
[Musik]
die letzte biografie gekocht und 61 also
theoretisch sind felix magath kann deine
fresse t shirt bezüglich anderes demand
bundesrat wird in schlag den medien
kritisiert nicht ganz zu unrecht
ob maßnahme werde irgendwie hinterfragt
und 100 das romantischste flavio 48
gespannt mit dem klettern
[Musik]
selbst ein drittes buch macht gesetzt da
schleicht simon schweizer ob sie
zerschnitt sowie ferien in der schweiz
gemachten dann stehen freiheit könne
machen was man will
steigt
[Musik]
ich würde jetzt nicht dass corona
kritiker also doch kritiker vielleicht
schon weil ich höchst kritisch weil sich
trotzdem ein echter bist großer manier
service erlaubt wenn ihm wenn ich mich
nicht wirklich weiß wo informiere mir
jetzt wo weiß sie dass das stimmt genau
möglich so kritischer aufpassen wo sein
alkohol gibt es nicht oder masken sind
staatlich oder nehmen wir einfach wunder
denn so wenn man fünf jahre zurückliege
wenn man wüsste was wirklich so wenn es
für elektrizität ich habe einfach viel
nüchterner lüge das ganze wie
informierte im moment ist die
fashionistas also über corona
informieren im momentanen große im
internet eine freundin klinik wegen der
posten mit den neuen regler was jetzt
gibt was man nur das nicht vielleicht
schon aber das infiziert die infizierte
zahle und alles interessiert möchte also
schließe ich aus juni betrifft befördert
media der meinung nach besser machen
jetzt sollte nicht so wie seelsorge
angst schüren oder oder angstmache und
und alles so schlimm da stelle ich meine
wir können ja immer noch einigermaßen
wenn wir waren aber es wird immer so
dargestellt wird immer wenn es da große
gross ballt untergang so war es ist
einfach klassisch die franken hexer die
krassesten schranke musikalisch am
anfang sieht die fünf personen regler in
der öffentlichkeit sich langsam summe
wurde allerhand prognose sie ihre als
nebulös kriegt aber herr kollege bruce
krieg kann weil sie auch zu sechst 70
sie sind und die scheint wirklich
nachvollziehbar sie weiß jetzt was jetzt
der unterschied macht und da haben es
die velos gefühlt dass ich schon angst
wenn man macht was man eben so gemacht
hat und dann plötzlich ist es illegal
und man kann es ja ganz nachvollziehen
wenn er ein bisschen wollte wird das
[Musik]
wer auf facebook sondern faustkämpfen 83
und das ist okay dass ich so sondern
zieht war in ihrer rückkehr mit
irgendwelchen naturheilpraxis
krebsgeschwüre und die entwicklung
machen
das zeigt wahrscheinlich habe das sind
wo man das krone gerade über allem steht
für die sagen so dass das im moment so
wie die zusage besinnliche vorhat wie
aufgestellt welches in romantisch
coronado und das ist keine große team
und klima ist
[Musik]
gar nicht gut
solistisch
marx ist politisches ziel waren sehr gut
vorteil von corona zum beispiel und das
e mail system hinterfragen ganz konsum
das brauchen wir auch nicht und b aber
eine frau des kapitalismus megane
funktioniert
ja also das gefühl im umfeld sind schon
ziemlich blutig wie antikapitalistischer
wurde und ich glaube es hat irgendwie
hierfür zeigt also ohne maske hautporen
hoffentlich nicht passiert ohne in der
die ganze internationale flüge hat das
nicht zu schaffen
es hat die sache schlecht belüftete
probleme schon dass ich sehe oder es ist
einfach nur sichtbar wurde
der film ist problem mit die ganze
massentierhaltung allein schon wie durch
krankheit und ihr depot hin zum beispiel
schweinegrippe oder saß auf um die 2 das
wäre nie passiert wenn man die vegan
werden aber ja aber wenn ich sage wieder
anders sieht es dadurch auf dass er
damit will ich nicht begangen wenn die
studie auch lebte sitzt die ganze
pandemie vielleicht nicht so schnell ab
und zu hinterfragen wenn sich im heck
haben krebs über macht und würde also
dass man den fortschritt nur dann auf
eine art ich glaube die wenigsten lied
hat sich ja auch für gedanken machen
über den kapitalismus oder übel wenn sie
sich vergangene oder niedriger jetzt
nicht aber so eine pandemie hatte
die tracht für yoga mehr
die schnittmenge zwischen auto und wurde
genau zu kennen wenn er wirklich so
homöopathie auf dem schotter corona und
natürlich die schnitt macht
bekanntschaft mit facebook kann ich
vielleicht hat dieser sache konfrontiert
ich habe ihm so viel busche klasse
herrsche so liegt im umfeld und mit
einer umgangen
wir haben ja viele leute im umfeld wo
ausländer auf das reagiert als ein
kollege von mir wenn ich ein ziel kennt
haben da ist mega völlig aus so
verschwörungstheorien und so und ist
jetzt teil fürs andere gruppierungen
sowie malte ristau eine zwanzig wäschen
mega liebenswerte versuchen also was er
meint das nicht irgendwie böse gemeint
haben
er warnte vor dem hoch so gerade
passiert ist als er ist sogar fest davon
überzeugt angehalten sich trotzdem
wichtig dass sie ernst nimmt will
wenn sie sich als menschen und respekt
respektiert für stelle gott zu auf das
sagt woran sie meint sehr gut
[Applaus]
unser ort geht einigermaßen mal wieder
etwas
das berichtet der langstrasse und einige
gehabt oder nicht lieber jetzt krank
hey wie gehts wieder mal einen technisch
zu leisten
der letzte richtige iscsi forum erster
lockt also nur im januar irgendwann
immer mehr schlagen konnte
nein das kann uns im lotto und so dass
ich alles ist dass ich es mache hier bei
der fall dass ich bin ja auch wichtig
aber das mit dem lüd rache an ihm jetzt
sollte also wissen gepaart ist etwas
großartiges und tücher der taliban
das stößt eigentlich steht wenn es jetzt
passiert war vielleicht kranich erkennt
frank tisch war da was ist passiert uns
fast und den wünschen des staates ist
die person vielleicht sagt 'du bist du
solltest du die folge statt
es ist mir bewusst dass es provokativ
und das ist sicher alle haben mit dem
könnte ja mit mir übereinstimmen da wo
auch wenn jetzt ja auch das ist wirklich
einfach grob fahrlässig und das beste
das mir voll bewusst wenn er das parkett
und reflektiert die eigentlich mehr als
touristische personen person wie mit so
zu dir was ist für mich persönlich das
mega wichtig soziale kontakte
psychosoziale kontakt- und es gar nicht
schlecht und ich wollte möglichst
maximal alle machen monitor
all jene und ich aber nicht die
psychische gesundheit fördern
das ist für mich der ganze ja
für mich ist das einfach hat das
immunsystem mega stern ist körperkontakt
und soziale kontakt und es ist sowieso
okay das was mit der mannschaft komplett
ist ja eigentlich das baden league
treffer wie solange diese vier teams zu
schwierig vierter seine atmosphäre sowie
entwickle sich einfach so die ganze
atmosphäre war sein klub hat strahlt
mega flieger im ort wohl ganz einfach
die von goslar war mit vier personen ist
wahrscheinlich ist dieser dienst hatte
hier und da muss die momente wo nie mit
mehr als zahlen zusammen sind das sind
18 hier wo man so halver
das sind so kleine insel und so dankte
genau vor atmosphäre vorladung von
lebendigkeit und dann wieder ganz gut
aushalten
bis hilft sowie hoffen dass er hoffe der
früheren wir hoffen das kleben
[Musik]
ich glaube so übernehmen und fertigung
sind große poren verstopfen
[Musik]
traum ja
dafür danke kurzfristig
dieses gefühl das ist ein stoff der sich
am ikv rechte großmutter und das team
hat charakter kann durchaus schwer mache
jeden schritt jede handbewegung wo du
machst dir wissen was schlechtes
gewissen aber wir werden jetzt der
vorstand habe ich eigentlich angst dass
ich das kontaminierte ich bin damit die
erste brille denn sie haben ja ein stück
weit mit abzocke bei einer männerdomäne
sind aus dem schlaf xi sind ja und ich
habe noch nie gesehen und sie so dort
dürfen frank saam preis auf einem
schrank verwechsle ich schon recht nah
und den schlussendlich aber recht
hässlich oder wichtig wäre nicht immer
noch verstand das noch knapp minute
glück immer nicht verständnis noch
maßnahme an sich sehe halt das kanalnetz
desinfiziere auf abstand sie ja darum
wie so eine kleine achterbahn der
gefühle momentan also werte so schlüssig
2 jörg soyk reiskirchen schon noch nicht
mehr so lang aber es ist auch abbruch
passierte version
es ist einfach alles innerhalb von einer
woche ist sie ein loch foto frank rieg
bis zum tod sein vorgänger und durchaus
schwieriger machen also ich habe einen
ins kiste war deutlich ein stolzes alter
aber müsste zeit nicht unbedingt cologne
als er
nach vermisst sie schon
die fertigung sie ich schenke dir jedes
enkel sehen dass er fast senkrecht bis
vortrag muss halt dir wo sie alle die
entweder corona wieder eine grüne spitze
und das alles über den livestream wonach
der facebook seite mir sehr aber wir
sind dann das gar nicht denn ich einen
stream ist anderen halt tropfen auf dem
heißen stein sich nicht rasch wir nicht
richtig abschieden es ist alles nur auf
die stange ja das macht es nicht
einfacher jetzt wenn sie die maske
umlauf feierlichen europa diese
erstattet also erster linie denke für pc
und auf der anderen verstauen ist halt
das ist für zwei spiele gesperrt weil
auf der anderen seite sind die ganze
party veranstaltet im nachtleben ja auch
nicht frage möchten haben wo das alles
hinführt wenn das jetzt noch sowie dem
wir uns einmal in clubs möge vielleicht
greifen
wo blieb den quasi noch über ganze spaß
marcel mir junge
im norden die ordnung machen wie viel zu
sagen schaffen
dank der ablenkung zum nachlesen
darüber hinwegkommen also ich freue mich
jedes mal zum geschäft der basis dieses
hobby und hitze zum treff gemacht also
nichts trinke so mixa ja
[Musik]
hey dad dieses cross team
[Applaus]
richtig manchmal wie ccs gesetz läuft
soll noch relativ gut
aber ja am 11 wer stunden vor dem
wochenende und kriegst du ja eigentlich
finde lockt also ich bin dafür aber dann
muss klar finanziert sie die letzten
vier wochen bis zum 11
die sperrstunden sie machen umsatz aber
kann richtig quote ungesagt sogar schon
nicht schlecht
die meisten der knapp user aber ich
beklage für den walk down aber dann muss
alles finanziert sie versuchen dauer
aber fahren genau wieso kommen müsste
weiß ich was ich mir persönlich bin ich
wirklich so wie es überall ist im körper
wenn man sich krank fühlt blieb die high
haltet abstand wie handys oder mache da
noch alles möglich dass man mir
irgendwann wieder ein normaler betrieb
wieder freuen konnte
[Musik]
mit 18 8 und 10 meter weniger ja wie ich
es früher ausgang ich meine enttäuschung
ist schon wieder montag das überhaupt
wenn es lohnt sich schon zum kollegin im
sommer geplant wo die eltern keine
stattfinden das ist schon eine weile her
dass es geschafft haben und das ist aber
nicht lange reise bildungsreise und
sport lage das soll es auch gesagt
worden dass ich immer so dass immer mehr
dazu und dann nicht mehr so sagt sie
nein das ist auch nur das auge und dann
im abschlussjahr und bildet heißt es das
highlight für jede fünfte mannschaft
geschenkt wird nicht mehr von peter
oppel riesige beruhigt und ich sage dass
ich sicher nicht einfach für uns aber
doch zanni wird wird man es nie
kennenlernen und das ist nicht möglich
und dann fragt man sich manchmal
schuljahr wann hört zu
schlimmer noch positiver so knapp nicht
mit sakko und den kontrollerwerb ich
danke sich dank immer genau so wichtig
dass mediator haltet und also man muss
einander lied danke man sieht wirklich
als ganzes land zusammen geben und auch
sie das
und ja ich glaube das gibt es heute
eigentlich zu einer schönen kurzarbeit
die dem hause team ist es 20 jährige sie
also die generation der besonders
krasses fremdartige für meine generation
weiter
doch liegen die probleme aber in meiner
generation zeit sehr wichtig sei der
future für signifikante machen sich
gedanken mehr konsum und weiten politik
und häufigsten solidarisch zeigen
größtenteils richtung ist er 0 und
machen so optimistisch und das mega cool
und das laub im fall so recht ruhig
schlafen
also macht
die geldstrom ist eine schenkung
schwierig sei es in dem kommentar